hello i'm gavin i'm dan you've joined us
in a very stupid slow-mo guys video that
suits me excuse me too those are often
the most fun it's a classic idea that's
been going around again on tick-tock and
youtube shorts and all that filling a
stretch armstrong until it explodes
giving it the slow-mo treatment this
time though yeah it's been messaged to
us probably a thousand times so we had
to get involved
i never had one of these as a kid
neither did i i honestly i was always
intrigued by him i had a little go on a
friend's one but looking back on it
would you ever get one of these and play
with it for more than about 95 seconds
well when i was younger i saw the
adverts and i thought absolutely not but
having played with it it's actually
quite intriguing i quite like it
apparently you can get rather sizable
when filled with water let's whip out
phantom and get filling yeah i've always
thought this head was too big for the
body i think we should change that
[Laughter]
2 000 frames a second today and uh i
think it's time to say goodbye to mr
armstrong there he is i'm going to give
him the jamie lannister treatment go in
from the arm here take his little hand
off
that's what's the what's the stuff
i think it's like oh i shouldn't have
done that why did i do that i instantly
regretted it
it's like a corn starchy type thing it's
like some weird surgery
oh
that is gross
okay
we're in it's
similar to your lambing comment
[Laughter]
zip tie around the wrist double zip tie
on my hat look at the grass stuck to my
hands it's so sticky i've never i've
actually never opened one before you've
never opened a stretch armstrong i mean
that's not really what they're for is it
did they stop making them weren't they
like a thing where you just couldn't get
hold of them anymore maybe they brought
them back because everyone was blowing
them up
yeah the executive's like
guys
we gotta bring it back back yeah
everyone's destroying them the amount of
people that send this to us was unreal
am i ready
it's a funny sight yeah it is a funny
sight
that's just making me laugh
oh god
it's full of air oh no because it's got
air in the thing
did you ever play a
theme hospital
oh
[Laughter]
oh it must have shot some of his glue
it's kind of like bloopy
oh much better
his legs like bent around look it's like
yeah try and work it work the water into
his extremities giving him the willy
wonka treatment
bit of a violet burrow yeah yeah this
swimwear is about the size of human
swimwear now yeah you could wear that
wearing some budgie smugglers
[Applause]
yeah his head's more in proportion now
might want to turn it off while the
clouds in
think about what your job is right now
you can release
state of it
where do you reckon he's going to go
from maybe from his crotch i mean that's
where most you know men's weaknesses are
between their legs so i think my money's
there too god he is filling this frame
right oh
oh oh where'd he go from oh they look
like intestines look at that
look at that
oh it literally looks like guts look at
his guts dripping oh this is graphic do
you know on the box it says
always returns to original shape
drinking
yeah
yeah
so
we said most men's
weak spots is the crotch let's see how
true that is
there we go his legs all like
bent underneath mangle yeah let's see
what we can if we can see where it
popped from
exactly on the crotch directly right on
the genitals
look at that couldn't be more perfect
what that was
oh i've got i'm happy with my prediction
what the chances oh and his head just
goes straight back blown off oh my
goodness
he's like his arms like
look at it
oh it's so
he's rapidly shrinking though look at
all the water getting kicked out of it
yeah it's so like gelatinous and all his
limbs just start undulating back to the
middle
uh it's gruesome it's got obviously torn
all the way across his body across his
arm and his arm fell off yeah yeah i i
enjoyed that thoroughly why don't we got
one more we've got one more yeah why
don't we have you
hold it
sit him in your lap just like
cross-legged on the floor
see how long you can bear hug him for
all right yeah
this is a sight
every time
what do you mean just every time every
time what you're setting up the cameras
when i'm doing something like this it's
just like i look so dumb
so ridiculous here comes the water
i'm gonna have to constantly readjust
this
oh gosh
this is such a weird sensation his leg
is cr there's like bent underneath me oh
what how many gallons is this am i going
to just get crushed doing this no
maybe
and it's barely started and it's pretty
heavy probably
it needs to like get get in there oh
[Laughter]
oh no
oh my sweaty wrists are hard i need to
be like can you like tie my wrists
together
try your wrist oh man it's so slippy and
hard i can see all of his guts floating
around inside
oh
good morning save my phone b
i'm glad he went when he did i didn't
have much left that was quite quick
actually
i'm clearly enjoying myself
you can see the strain in your face
it was hard my wrist was slippy and he
was getting massive where's he burst
from he doesn't look like he got as big
as when he was on the floor because uh
because my the arm is like not even oh
straight down the middle i think it's
from the crotch again again
just watching the headline back as well
he just goes oh he's sucked down
but your reaction time was quite quick
then you blinked immediately well i mean
not immediately but it's pretty quick
pretty quick yeah i mean stretch arms
had already started going down by that
point but it's still not not bad and now
you're just hugging nothing
did your arms come into your chest uh i
don't think so they were mostly just in
your mouth
corn syrup in there how did that happen
yeah i wasn't really like pulling him
towards me i was just locking my wrists
your face is often a masterpiece and
slower i was just about to readjust the
camera too when that happened so i'm
glad i didn't i was about to zoom in a
little bit
my baby
i popped
wet sock competition going on there oh
that's foul
all right
i've brought you into the edit
okay it's a first is
but there's something that we didn't
notice
at the time i've been you told me this
days ago
i've been trying to rack my brains i
can't possibly imagine what it is
i see it
i see it
he's he's peered
why is he peeing he's just taking a leak
he's just he started just leaking out of
his knuckle he's literally taking a leak
oh that's where it popped from wow
not only that
oh he's doing it again
what
ah
what a weird feature so it's happened
every time we've done it how small is
that hole it's got to be less than a
millimeter the funny thing is i couldn't
feel that because i was holding it well
it would have been so quick as well yeah
so um
he just he just pees a little bit first
and then he and then you burst
let's go again
you reckon that'll happen again it's
pretty consistent
it's going to get tight on the hole yep
all right so we're going to try again
and i'm going to focus
around here
but obviously that will be over here by
the time that's happening so try and get
it
oh god
oh
[Music]
yeah you were right you nailed it right
in the middle yeah like you knew exactly
where it was going to be it's just like
right in the middle of his
his pants so it's this point where it
splits and it's very similar but it's
slightly uh i guess there's some
variance but it's always in the shorts
oh
he's got a torn torso
the water's mixing with his glue and
it's just becoming gelatinous dripping
down i think it is like some sort of
corn syrup or something it's weird yeah
maybe we should bounce one on a speaker
especially like this bit here
hopefully you enjoyed that stupidity i
think it delivered on that front uh make
sure you subscribe if you like slow-mo
and send us other things that you'd like
us to replicate
with our high-speed cameras
see you next time bye-bye question mark
yeah